what exactly can the pontiff help
President Obama with though so there are
key elements of what Pope Francis has
been talking about with regularity over
the last year so that the White House
actually thinks very much sir helps its
agenda and I want to talk about three
that he will be talking about while he's
here economic inequality this has been a
big White House issue that they've been
trying to address through policy
functions that have mostly been blocked
on Capitol Hill so that'll be one
climate changes another one he brought
it out in his encyclical recently the
White House is seized on that and tried
to use that as momentum to push forward
at least on the executive branch side
vaani but I want to talk about the last
one which i think is really important on
Friday he's going to be in Philadelphia
so if you look through his schedule he
arrives on tuesday night the president
will go out of his way to actually visit
him when he arrives something the
president rarely does wednesday he's at
the White House for big ceremony and to
talk with the president Thursday joint
session of Congress then he goes to New
York City you'll speak to the UN why is
it the UN he'll address climate change
the White House big hopes for that
speech but when he goes to Philadelphia
this weekend he'll be talking about
criminal justice reform that has been a
big push from the White House and
President Obama over the last six to
twelve months they think that push right
there there's some bipartisan support on
Capitol Hill for that if the Pope adds
some momentum to that that's something
that the White House actually thinks
they can move forward on Capitol Hill
avani well there have been any
coordination between the Pope's people
if you like and President Obama's people
on what the Pope is actually going to
address here on logistics yes on the
actual substance of the remarks now I've
been talking to white house officials
about this and there's kind of there's
excitement about the visit no doubt
about it the president thinks very
highly of Pope Francis he regularly
talks about his one-on-one meeting with
Pope Francis at the Vatican last year
however there's caution about it look
the White House is not aligned with the
Vatican with Pope Francis on everything
the White House splits with Catholic
teachings when it comes to abortion when
it comes to gay marriage so there's
caution about what he's going to say I
talked to one White House official who
made clear vaani look we look forward to
what the Pope has to say but we know
much better than to try and get involved
with what he's going to say I guess well
I thought the Wall Street Journal did a
great job Toni Morrison the Nobel
laureate I am a lapsed Catholic but Pope
Francis is impressive enough to make me
reconsider my arrow we look for error
with Michael McKee
surveillance that really speaks to the
moment doesn't it does fill quickly
gotta ask you about this report that the
u.s. speaking of Cuba may abstain at the
UN from the annual condemnation of the
u.s. Cuba embargo yeah Mike that's what
we're hearing right now from officials
is that's a possibility and I what
aligns with basically is what this
administration is said the president has
called for Congress to remove the
embargo the trade embargo that's been in
place since the very end of Dwight
Eisenhower's administration has called
for him to vote on that Congress is not
going to move on that so long as
Republicans are in control the House and
Senate so this is a way to show Mike if
they go through with this that that's
what they want like Phil thank you so
much Phil Mattingly and wants you to